welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast
to help you grow your influence on
youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact
and a high profit online business my
name is heather torres
and i want to welcome you if you are new
here to the podcast make sure you
subscribe so that you never miss an
upload that happens every single tuesday
and i'm excited because
at the end of this episode i'm gonna
tell you how you can win an
all-access pass to our grow with video
live conference
happening in the fall of 2021 so stay
tuned to the end of today's
episode now let's dive into today's
featured content where sean cannell goes
into
is it too late to get started on youtube
is it too late to start youtube in 2021
the answer
is yes and no and i'm gonna be
explaining
in detail in this episode but here are
some facts that you need to know
about youtube you know number one is
that
youtube is the most popular video
platform
on the web and over the last decade
youtube has seen
unprecedented growth that growth has
only been accelerated
by the events that happened in 2020 with
lockdowns and the pandemic that
change people's behavior in unimaginable
ways with the majority of people staying
at home and watching even more content
on
screens fact youtube is still
the second most visited website in the
world and the second most used social
network fact youtube hosts over 2
billion
logged in users every month that's
almost one-third
of the internet and the consumption for
videos
is high because there's more users and
youtube is getting billions of hours of
videos being watched and
billions of video views every single
day so is it too late to start youtube
on a surface level it's not i mean
there's so much action there
we're gonna look at some of the enemies
that could hold us back
but is there competition sure is there
going to be challenges
absolutely but anything worthwhile in
life
is uphill it's going to take energy it's
going to take
putting in the time to do the work but
when you consider how big
the audience is when you consider how
many people on youtube
you really have massive opportunity
ahead of you
if you overcome the seven areas we're
going to discuss in this video
but as far as why it is or it isn't too
late to start youtube i think henry ford
the famous
inventor of the ford motor card said it
this way whether you think you can
or you think you can't you're right is
it too late to start youtube well if you
think it is then it is for you
is it too late to start youtube if you
think you can and you think you could
still succeed well then for you
it's not too late because now that i've
been on this platform since 2007
the first channel i started on youtube
was for my small church in a small
small town an hour north of seattle
every
few years people started asking this
question i remember 2012 people were
like man is it too late to start youtube
now the ch
it's seven years old 2015 people are
like oh it must be too late to start
2018 people are like is it too late to
start youtube and there was two types of
people
those a couple years ago that said ah
it's too late and then there were those
who started
and today they have reached their
youtube
goals of course some are still building
but i think of people that just started
in the last couple years
we just got a message i got a dm from
cass who has a career development
channel she said hey
i'm excited to join one of our mission
to help 10
000 people go full time on youtube mark
me as one of the ten thousand i'm
quitting my job
and she sent me the date i was like this
is crazy and guess when she
reached that goal yes in 2021
when did she start youtube just in the
last couple years there's people that
have started in just the last year that
have still grown
so whether you think you can or you
think you can't
you're right and what i've learned is
that there's some myths
and there's really some excuses that
prevent you
from the life and the youtube channel
you want and that if we can overcome
these that we actually will be able to
reach our youtube goals this
year you know jeff bezos the founder of
amazon
said this complaining is not a strategy
you have to work with the world as you
find it
not as you would have it to be off from
the top i want to encourage you
if you if you are even in places and
having conversations
and spending a lot of energy just being
like oh man it's too late oh that ship
sailed
oh man maybe if i would have started
youtube last year it would have worked
man is it too late now man i've been
watching youtube videos about if it's
too late now for the last 10 hours
i've been spending the last month just
watching other content pondering and
wondering if i should post videos
well guess what imagine if you invested
all that time into actually building
something
and he said listen you have to work with
the world as it is not as you would have
it to be
was it easier to start and build a
youtube channel in 2015
probably when's the best time to plant a
tree
five years ago when's the second best
time to plant a tree today
like it was probably easier but there's
also advantages today
so let's get into these things the
reality is this you can have excuses or
you can have results you just can't have
both
and so here's some of the excuses or
myths or things i hear people say of why
they can't start youtube and we're going
to disprove all of them
so you can crush your youtube goals this
year number one i
don't know how i don't know how
i don't know how to start a youtube
channel i don't know how to use my
camera
i don't know what i would film on i
don't know what i would talk about you
cannot
say i don't know how in 2021 did you
know that our cell phones today have
more computing power
than all of nasa
back in 1969 when they placed two
astronauts
knots on the moon are you kidding me now
my wife doesn't actually believe that
event happened but we know that it did
here's the deal nasa placed two people
on the moon and your smartphone
has more power than the technology they
had then you can start a youtube
channel and figure out how did you know
that a masai warrior on a mobile phone
in the middle of kenya has better
mobile communications than a u.s
president did 25 years ago
yeah he's on it and if he's on a
smartphone with google he has access to
more information
than the u.s president had 15 years ago
i don't know how
give me a break you can find out how
where there's a will
there's a way where there's google
there's an answer
where there's youtube you can learn and
think about it
even without all the other channels just
in the world of think media like why
aren't you
sitting down getting a notebook getting
a pen getting focus
shutting out distractions and watching
we have like a
free how to create videos college
available to you
on youtube it's called think media and
you're going to learn from nolan and
omar and heather and tony
breaking down how to use cameras and how
to get better lighting and how to take
thumbnails and how to edit are you
kidding
i don't know how can we just label it
what it is it's an excuse
and not knowing is a myth that is
holding
you back and many other people listen
number two
i don't have a good idea and there's too
much competition
i don't have a good idea or maybe it's
this one you know what someone stole my
idea
my friends there's nothing original
anymore you know king solomon said this
like 3000 years ago he said there's
nothing new under the sun now obviously
there's new things like now there's an
app called clubhouse where you can lose
five to ten to fifteen hours real quick
and maybe it was good or maybe it
distracted you from actually building
the things you should be focusing on
and crushing your priorities but here's
the deal i don't have a good idea
michael dell the founder of dell
computers said this
ideas are a commodity execution of them
is not it's not too late to start
youtube
if you commit to taking massive action
there's tons of ideas there's a million
good ideas in fact i struggle with idea
syndrome i got 20 youtube channels i
want to start today
there's so many dang good ideas and so
many ideas that either have happened or
haven't happened yet whatever
the real game though is the execution of
the ideas
and if you put a decent idea into action
you're gonna beat
everybody else who's just thinking all
day long about whether whether or not
they have a good idea
and here's actually an encouraging fact
about rising competition on youtube
crowded markets equal lots
of potential viewers and customers yeah
if your idea is already on youtube and a
lot of people are getting views around
that idea and that concept
that's proof that there's interest in
that
man i'm stunned i got friends that do
what what are called faceless channels
and they've learned that sometimes they
got 10 or 20 or 30
faceless channels that are in niche
topics with b-roll and voice-overs and
they're not in the actual videos and
they've learned that there is an
endless appetite for good content
around topics that people are passionate
about an endless appetite
that sometimes they've got multiple
channels about the same thing and people
just watch channels
they watch video after video after video
it makes sense when you love something
when you're into something when you're
obsessed with something good content
will always win cream always rises to
the top no matter how many cups of
coffee
you pour you just gotta put out good
content and crowded markets
equal lots of viewers and lots of
customers and here's the good news about
ideas is success leaves clues
i would actually challenge you that if
you want to win on youtube this year and
start
put a new spin on a proven idea don't be
looking for an
absolutely original idea like by the way
if you got something really amazing like
go for it you feel passionate about it
but chances are if it's so unique and so
different and like
zero other people are doing it chances
are no one's interested in it and that's
going to be a harder
youtube channel to pioneer the best path
is putting a new spin
your unique spin your unique personality
on a proven idea a proven topic a proven
niche a proven
niche on youtube number three i don't
let me know if you're guilty of this one
i don't have enough time you know i
don't know if it's too late to start
i'm so busy i don't know if i have
enough time like i just don't think i
have enough time
to build a youtube channel listen
can we talk it straight we've been
talking straight but can i can i
tell it to you straight you have the
same 24 hours
as dave ramsey oprah
kanye west mr beast reese witherspoon
and the most productive person you know
you got the same 24 hours
like i don't know about you like you're
not stopping the sun you're not hitting
pause on the clock
we all have the same 24 hours the
difference is
how you use your time truth
nobody is too busy it's just a matter of
priorities truth
if it is important to you you will find
a way if it's not you'll find an excuse
i really believe this could be your year
on youtube sure there's rising
competition but if
execution is the game you got to get
discipline
you got to start start taking some
responsibilities you can either make
excuses or you can get results
and meanwhile why the majority friend
are going to be making excuses and
wondering if their idea is going to work
or not
or wondering if they should start or not
or just debating if it's too late
meanwhile a small percent of people are
going to be taking massive action
getting super disciplined with their
calendar getting super focused with
their strategy and putting
massive action into their youtube
channel and those are the channels
that are gonna grow you know another one
that i hear number four is i don't have
connections
man it's not what you know it's who you
know man if i only knew
somebody big on youtube if i only had
somebody to shout me out
that's not true it's not a valid excuse
today for one reason
because social media makes it possible
to connect with just about anyone
like you can reach just about anyone and
make strategic connections leveraging
social media
but youtube does not work because of
connections it works because of content
you're probably better off shutting
yourself into a room
and focusing on creating great content
rather than making
and even worrying about i don't have
connections focus on great
content number five i'm too old i'm too
old you know youtube's just for the
young whippersnappers
youtube's just for the the gen ziers the
zoomers
okay boomer listen i'm not you're not
too old
have you seen donia angelo's channel
like she's
she's got like this my kitchen to your
house
channel where she cooks in her clay kind
of
stove kitchen and she's definitely like
in her legacy here she's kind of like
this really sweet grandma
i think about gray matters my friend
who's got a
a uh dottotech has a show called gray
matters
guess what he teaches he helps people
like affiliate marketing and webinars
and online marketing
but he's talking to baby boomers i think
about ryan's toy review
like he's on the other side of things i
think about that five-year-old that's
got like eight youtube channels
in russia like there's people at
every age in spectrum and here's what i
would challenge you with
you know if you can discover one person
that's like you reaching the goals that
you have for yourself
you just lost the excuse and you will be
able to find
any ethnicity age demographic
situation disability all of them
at this point on youtube every single
excuse has been disproven by someone
that is growing their channel right now
not trying to say it's easy i'm not
saying that you're not going to have an
uphill battle
but i am saying it's possible and you
got to remember that you're never too
old to accomplish
anything that you set your mind to you
know author c.s lewis has this awesome
quote i love this
you're never too old to set another goal
or dream a new dream
stop just dwelling on is it too late
i don't have enough time is do i have a
good idea or not
i don't know if i know how i don't know
if i have enough connections no
like it's never too late to start if you
start
today and you get super disciplined
super strategic super planned out
and you focus on execution not just
dreaming
pondering and wondering if you should
start or not number six
i don't have enough money man you know
the rich get richer
you know you need money to start if i
had enough money have you ever thought
this or heard this before
ah no one ever gave me a shot no one
ever gave me an opportunity
listen exclusive excuses are a
vulnerability to you
they might even be true but they're not
helpful they're a waste of energy
they're a waste of time
and we can disprove this one number one
because youtube is free
number two because if you're hearing my
voice right now
chances are you're on a pretty nice
smartphone
chances are you're in a car with some
kind of bluetooth connection on some
device
chances are you're on a really nice
laptop or pc that is
fully capable of starting creating
content like youtube is free
you have if you have a smartphone and
access to the internet you can start
this continually happens and i've
learned this that it's actually not
about your resources it's about your
resourcefulness
so if you think man i just don't have a
head you know enough of a head start
is it a fact that the
expectation of production value on
youtube is rising this year i think so
i do think that people want content that
has good audio
good lighting that they want content
that's well edited
well organized but man when you start
getting scrappy
when you start getting a little chip on
your shoulder and you start thinking man
where there's a will there's a way you
know it's not about my resources
it's about my resourcefulness i'm gonna
take my smartphone
shoot it golden hour so the lighting is
perfect stack it up on a box and use
some duct tape
in a quiet park so the audio is good
standing close to the phone so that they
can actually hear good audio because i
can't afford a mic yet
prepare my content and deliver something
valuable and i'm gonna go to starbucks
and upload that video
i'm gonna go to the library and upload
that video oh we're on lockdown i'm
gonna
sit in my car in front of somebody
else's house and hack onto the internet
and upload that video
i'm gonna find a way to edit it on my
phone post it from my phone
i am gonna watch think media's free
video
where heather taurus breaks down how to
shoot with a smartphone
edit on a smartphone create a thumbnail
on a smartphone and upload
from a smartphone again if you got
access to this content i'm empathetic
if you are in a remote village no
internet no power no electricity
yes it would be very difficult to grow
on youtube in that situation but i have
a feeling if you're listening to this
that's not your circumstances
so never say i don't have enough money
get resourceful
and then number seven and if we're
honest
this is one i think we all struggle with
at honestly every level
it's just i'm scared it's the excuse of
i'm scared like maybe like i'm afraid
i'm i'm afraid of failing
you know sean if i'm honest like it's
i'm not actually wondering if it's too
late i'm just i'm i'm wondering though
if if i am going to be wasting my time
by investing in a youtube channel right
now i wonder if i
if i try this and i fail what is my
spouse going to think what's my family
going to think
i wonder if i try this like i'm afraid
of looking dumb
i'm afraid of what even though i've been
out of high school for 10 years i'm
afraid of what sarah from high school is
going to think about me and how she's
going to judge me
news flash sarah doesn't even know what
you're doing anymore like she's going
through
her own problems today and trying to
figure out
her own situation she's not thinking
about you but you might be thinking
about what other people are thinking
and dealing with fear here's the deal if
i could be
real with you as soon as every year
passes on youtube i think
is this going to keep going what if
youtube gets shut down
what if another video pro form emerges
what if what if what if and guess what i
could spin myself out
i could worry and wander and anxiety for
the next five weeks
wondering about possible scenarios like
what good
is even wondering what if what if a
meteorite hits the earth right now well
then we don't really need to worry about
it do we much
what if a an emp you know like hits
and all power goes down and all the
servers well yeah like we're gonna be in
a serious situation if that happens
what good is what if well in the
meantime
instead of asking what if you could be
focusing on building and maximizing
today i can't make you any promises
nobody else that you watch on youtube or
listen to on a podcast can make you any
promises about what tomorrow tomorrow
holds
but at the beginning of this episode we
broke down the opportunity
the audience the fact that youtube is
only growing the fact that
it is at your fingertips to be able to
create content the fact that you can
figure out anything
not just how to create a video but how
to make a good video not just how to
make content but how to make good
content
not just how to communicate but to
become a great communicator if there's a
will
there's a way and there's ways to punch
fear
in the face and you gotta just press
record
i love the cowboy john wayne famous he
was in lots of westerns and
it was kind of an actor that my dad my
stepdad phil grew up with and he always
watched these john wayne movies
one of john wayne's quotes was courage
is being scared
to death but saddling up anyway
listen you might be scared what if i
waste time this year you might
but what's the alternative if you do
nothing
then you're going to have a whole lot of
regret and guess what if you're going to
have is what if i did something
different in my past
you can't go back all you have is today
what if you took action today and what
if we flip the what if
what if you reach 10 000 subscribers
what if you can call your boss and tell
them that you're it's
you're ready to go part time what if
you're able to call your boss and say
i'm giving in my two weeks
what if you are getting emails and
comments from people saying your content
changed
my life what if you were able to buy
that dream house
what if you were able to give to the
causes that matter most to you what if
there's so much waiting for you on the
other side of fear
and meanwhile most people are stuck
wondering what if what if i try and fail
here's the deal
you may be disappointed if you fail but
you're doomed if you don't try
it's not too late to start youtube 2021
it's not gonna be too late to start
youtube in 2022 or 2023.
well sean what if youtube comes and what
if there's a takeover and what if
for sure i mean of course there's always
but
i think we can put the what ifs to the
side and realize that
come on there's a window of opportunity
but
a lot of times the opportunity of a
lifetime is missed
if it's not seized during the lifetime
of that opportunity
now's the time to seize the opportunity
of youtube and i think about one of the
biggest youtubers mr beast who's in an
interview and he said
they said what are you going to be doing
for the next couple years he goes you
know for me i could see it
until about 2025 just this youtube's
going nowhere
it's the dominant platform no one can
come close with the amount of library of
content
no one can come close with the
technological infrastructure
there continues to be more viewers it
continues to be refined as a platform no
other video platform's even close
listen everything you do in life is
going to have a level of risk to it
the definition of entrepreneur which if
you're listening to this
you are an entrepreneur is someone who
takes on
a disproportionate amount of risk
to start a business someone who takes on
a disproportionate amount of financial
risk to build something of course
there's going to take risk
but i'll tell you this there's a reason
we're going all in on youtube not just
because we've been here
but because it's the best platform in
fact this year we're actually narrowing
our focus to get more focused on youtube
because it's the only platform where
content lives forever it's the second
largest search engine in the world
the algorithm is so dang powerful that
you can create content today
that will still impact people tomorrow
and when you really catch a vision for
it
you start looking a couple years ahead
and you go dang if i create really good
content today
that's going to be feeding my kids three
years from now
it's not too late to start youtube i am
not saying it's going to be easy but i
am saying it's going to be worth it and
i want to encourage you
to kill these excuses kill the what ifs
and just put your blinders on and take
massive action
it doesn't even matter if your idea is
that good ideas are a commodity
execution of them is not a commodity if
you want to be
in the top five percent of youtube
creators you just got to take action
and stay consistent and persevere so i
encourage you this is your year
punch fear in the face punch
perfectionism in the face
and press record
[Music]
wow sean really killed our excuses
on that one it really is whatever you
determine it to be
whether you think it is or you think it
isn't it's up to you
and he walked through so many of the
excuses that we hear
inside of our community when people are
asking is it too late
have i missed the mark am i past the
opportunity
of this gold mine of youtube and while
it does take work
there are so many internal excuses that
we need
to crush and it really is all about
remembering
that no matter what you do if you just
stay committed
if you upload that next video if you
keep grinding if you keep going
if you do the philosophy that that i
love i will until
that you can really change your reality
you know i have
seen this happen firsthand with so many
people who started from nothing and were
able to
not only just grow an online influence
but we're able to quit their job we're
able to pay their mortgage we're able to
buy that fun thing or go on that fun
trip
or buy their dream house because they
just stuck with it so
is it too late to start that question's
for you are you ready to put in the time
are you ready to put in the commitment
are you ready to crush
these excuses that shawn just laid out
and go all in this year
because i can guarantee you that
yourself
a year from now is gonna wish that you
had started so i want you to grab your
camera this week when you press record
and i want you to get
that video uploaded because if you hold
back
if you keep waiting it will always be
too late for you to start
and we are going to keep this
conversation going about crushing our
excuses
going all in on youtube at our annual
conference
grow with video live and if you would
like to rate and review this podcast
you'll be entered in to win one of our
three all-access
passes for this exclusive virtual
event now that means that you can win
this pass and attend from anywhere in
the world all you need to do is rate and
review this podcast on itunes
and then go to thinkmarketingshow.com
for all of the details i'll make sure to
link everything down in the show notes
below
so that you have all that you need to
enter in to win one of these three
all-exclusive passes to grow with video
live
2021 and when you rate and review the
podcast
i get to read your review and today i
want to shout out
carrie carrie said great content from
sean and think media i've learned so
much from sean and the think team over
the last year
the content and training is always great
and this podcast
is no exception a must listen for
impact-driven entrepreneurs
carrie i just want to say thank you so
much for that content
you are really edifying exactly who
we're talking to
here on the think podcast we're talking
to you carrie the
impact driven entrepreneur and i hope
that this episode
all the episodes in the past and all of
the amazing content we have scheduled
for you in the future
that's going to help you grow your
influence with youtube and i can't wait
to see carrie
another review in a year from now where
you tell us all the impact that this
podcast has helped you with
thank you so much for listening to this
podcast again make sure you're
subscribed wherever you're consuming
this content from and
share it with a friend if you've not yet
shared this podcast
with the creator in your life i'm going
to challenge you this week to share out
this episode or an episode that has
impacted you
here from the podcast thanks for
listening and we'll catch you on the
next episode
[Music]
you